having an infinite mindset comes from
you wanting people to win more than you
want them to win with you you want
people to win around you your friends
your family your team your customers the
people you interact with you want them
to win as people in their life in their
goals whatever they want to accomplish
you want them to win more than you want
them to win with you if you can start to
adopt that mindset it really starts to
shift how you see your relationships how
you see your business how do you see the
people on your team and it allows so
much more positive energy to flow in the
right direction for everybody to
accomplish this